starmania n'a pas pris une ride l'opéra
rock créée par michel berger réapparaît
dans une cinquième version signée
maurice fleuret sur la scène de mogador
l'exception culturelle est respectée
chante en français
l'amitié culturel est respecté il chante
une fois par semaine en anglais gérard
dalmas jean-françois tonel invitation à
2h d'airs célèbres starmania l'histoire
d'une bande marlou terroristes les
étoiles noires qui s'opposent à
l'accession au pouvoir d'un candidat
président de l'occident toile de fond
une cité déshumanisé
partagez mon cas un chanteur
quand
en courant
j'ai écrit un opéra futuriste et
finalement la réalité a beaucoup
rattraper la fiction
je crois qu aujourd'hui sa touche encore
plus les gens opéra rock bande dessinée
beaucoup d'émotion servi par des bois
magnifique et décors bien planté donc
j'ai pris des experts en arts martiaux
et en acrobaties qui ont apporté cette
violence et cette énergie mais aussi des
chanteurs johnny rockfort il est
ceinture noire en karaté et justement je
pense que eux aussi oui toutes sont des
athlètes
oui
de l'univers
madonna
ces nouveaux talon est connue ne le
resteront pas longtemps chaque soir à
mogador 10 800 nouveaux star maniaque